more people are living in slavery today
than at any other time in history
today is the world day against human
trafficking designed to raise awareness
of the problem
it's a one aspect of modern day slavery
but there the united nations estimates
more than 40 million people worldwide
are trapped in some form of slavery
women and girls make up around 70
percent of the victims
many are exploited for sexual slavery
while the problem is said to be most
prevalent in africa and asia
there's also an estimated 1.5 million
slaves in the developed world
police here in germany recently made
arrests linked to a suspected
international smuggling ring
although the vast majority of people who
are trafficked are women and young girls
men are trafficked as well we have this
report from pakistan about a man who was
kidnapped and forced to work
in quarries for years before escaping
his captors he's still coming to terms
with the time he spent
as a slave
this television and video recorder are
the only luxuries muhammad arif has
he lives in a small nine square meter
simple hut
in northern pakistan arif once had a
family
and a job and was happy but then as a
young adult
he was kidnapped by three men
they put something over my head and i
lost consciousness
when i regained my senses i had no idea
where i was
they brutalized me over and over again i
remember that
to this day
they held him captive for more than 20
years
he worked up to 16 hours a day in a
quarry like this one
breaks were not allowed anyone who sat
down was beaten by the guards
but he remembers that the nights were
even worse than the days
at night they would lock us up and put
us in chains
they threw food at us that you wouldn't
even give to dogs
it was barbaric that's how i spent my
life there with no contact to the
outside world
arif was also unable to contact his wife
shamim bibi
she spent several years desperately
trying to find her husband
eventually she gave up thinking he was
dead and so
she looked for a new husband
we searched everywhere for him called
all the hospitals
but at some point we had no strength
left it had been 10 years
the children were still small and i
needed someone to take care of them
according to un figures between 600 and
800
000 people are victims of trafficking
every year
in pakistan officially documented cases
have declined in recent years
but the crimes still continue to this
day
in pakistan this happens mostly in
remote areas
where there is hardly any infrastructure
and a lack of education
the perpetrators then kidnap people and
receive a reward
most of the times the victims are put to
work
as fate would have it muhammad arif is
still hauling stones
and manages to scrape by doing this work
at least he's no longer doing it as a
slave laborer
because one morning he decided to jump
off the boat that took him and the other
men to work
i jumped into the water and started
swimming then they shot at me
but i was lucky and they didn't hit me
for hours i kept swimming at some point
i dared to get out of the water
it was night but i made it to the next
village where they helped me
a few years ago he came back to his home
village of haripur
he still suffers from the trauma of that
time
to this day he has not found a way to
regain his life
for more on this story we can speak now
to siobhan malali in galway ireland
she is the un special rapporteur on
human trafficking
welcome to dw we just saw there in our
report the incredible story
of a survivor of human trafficking but
he does have a unique story so what does
usually end up happening to people
who are trafficked
well what happens can really vary the
your report just highlighted that some
very few survivors
do escape from their traffickers
and may receive assistance from local
communities from
service providers from ngos police
or others but many continue for years
in situations of severe exploitation
in the context of sexual exploitation
they may be repeatedly raped
beaten enclosed within apartments or
houses
and forced into prostitution others in
the context of labor exploitation
are forced to work for years with little
or no
payments and often subject to very
severe physical abuse
along with the labor exploitation so the
the it is a very serious human rights
violation and one that can continue
over many years and the number of
trafficking victims especially
children has gone up uh in recent years
siobhan what impact
has the pandemic had the pandemic has
had a very serious impact and
this is a concern as we see children
out of school increasingly online
and therefore at risk of traffickers who
work
online who seek to groom and identify
children
and recruit them into situations of
armed conflict
labor exploitation but also of course
online sexual exploitation
and with the collapse of informal
economies in many parts of the world
we see rising unemployment we see
migrant workers being returned home
with nothing to support them and
children may become
a key source of income so we are also
seeing and hearing reports of increases
in child marriage
and this is a very serious concern we
also saw this in the context of the
ebola crisis in west africa
where we saw increases in exploitation
of children and women in particular
who tend to be concentrated in informal
economies
we tend to talk about trafficking in the
context of developing countries but it
does
also exist in the developing world so
what do you see there
it trafficking can happen anywhere so
it may be in the construction sector it
may be in restaurants and tourism
it may be in the context of sexual
exploitation
it's often hidden in plain sight uh so
it it
it's all around us um and we see in
particular
uh workers being exploited in
agriculture
in fruit picking in vegetable picking
in the construction sector and and in
the context of hospitality and
restaurants and
not enough resources are going into
labor inspectorates
uh to supporting trade unions to
supporting worker-led initiatives
a concern also is in the context of the
pandemic that fewer victims are being
identified and this was
reported also in the context of pakistan
but this is happening everywhere as
law enforcement resources are being
diverted
as ngos find it more difficult to
operate we're not seeing as many victims
being identified and referred for
protection
if you could identify one priority one
measure that could be implemented to
implement it to address human
trafficking
in the short term what would that be
i think we really need to see what is
happening in supply chains
in the context of labor exploitation and
in particular
exploitation of children where we see
children
being forced into labor exploitation in
the context of cocoa plantations tobacco
plantations
high numbers of children being
trafficked for the purpose of labor
exploitation
particularly in the west african region
but generating
huge profits for multinational
corporations
and we really need to move beyond
looking at voluntary compliance by the
business sector
and taking seriously what is happening
and identifying victims of trafficking
in their supply chains
we will have to leave it there siobhan
mullally un's special rapporteur on
human trafficking good to have you with
us
thank you